hey uh David any advice for someone who
wants to pursue a relationship with a
Korean I'm born and raised in the U.S I
don't even know what that means so this
is what you have to do so when you meet
her right you actually have to take like
a whole head of kimchi and I want you to
rub it on your chest
[Music]
now go to her parents and say she buys
that key
[Music]
Shiba seki and that means I want to date
your daughter and then you're going to
say
[Music]
and that means that I'm going to love
your daughter for the rest of her life I
want you to only speak in a Korean
accent it's a I love your daughters
every test and every day your daughter
come here she giving me a white person a
Korean a bonus